what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Glass Onion and knives out mystery
knives out two Ryan Johnson from The
Last Jedi we like him here midnight
shoot and John came back from Colorado
today made it how are you I am good it
was it was a harrowing Adventure but I'm
here and I'm ready for Ryan Johnson you
re-watch Knives Out in the terminal you
said yeah yeah that was actually perfect
I did not re-watch knives out it's good
we'll get some kind of perspective well
I'm a little bit bloated something went
wrong at the wedding I wasn't able to
enjoy the food that's a story for
another time so I treated myself last
night
but hey I'll get my energy up in just a
minute
anyway guys Cinema will pick you up
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also full length watch along
as we sync up with your own copy of
Glass Onion available for super sexy
rejects thank you for everyone who
supported us also I've been wearing this
shirt and videos recently I haven't even
shattered it out this is a real rejects
exclusive if anyone knows me they know I
hate the word influencer I constantly
like to clown on what an influencer is
and this is a shirt I've been wanting to
make for a long time so this is
available at shopzeroedition.com it's
Rorschach from Watchman inspired of who
influences the influencers personally
one of my favorites just because this
this one means a lot to me for some
reason so yeah it's a great way to
support the channel
um you go ahead and get yourself a shirt
uh this holiday season anywho let's
watch glass on you
foreign
thing and like now what's she running
for mayor of Westview and with me now is
Connecticut Governor Claire debella
whose Senate campaign is picking up
steam oh it takes place during the
pandemic
Uber for biospheres
I don't know okay maybe AI in dogs
equals discourse it does let's do it
what
no phones why can't she have a phone
because she's afraid that I will tweet
an ethnic slur
didn't even know that that word referred
to Jewish people I thought it was a
generic term for cheap oh
this is topical there's got to be a way
to open it it's solid there's no latches
or even visible seams the wood grain
pattern's weird though it's like it's
familiar it's the lament configuration
and the answer is no Jimmy Kimmel I do
not hate boobs I mean there's nothing
wrong with that right babe I love my
boobs there's fun
[Music]
I've been calling you you gotta answer
me when I call will you shut it we've
been over this a million times I told
you when me and whiskey alive you gotta
listen oh slap it dookie
I'm sorry
you got a delivery it's in the kitchen
nice seeing him play against type a
little bit yeah my mom already broke it
it's a stereo Brown
stereogram were those the same Magic Eye
things
whoa is that how those really work yeah
like those old books of the library
[Music]
damn cool so it's it's set up for a
maiden one should I do it gasparah whoa
maybe in one of the other puzzles it's a
compass ma it's a compass
I have loving the cast so far it's music
guys it's music it's music are you
mocking me yes when you layered this
tune on top of itself it starts to
change and turns into a beautiful new
structure
cool all together now one two three
[Music]
what is that
disruptors that's the Glass Onion well
spotted long weekend on my private
island and I hope your puzzle solving
skills are wetted
because you will also be competing to
solve the mystery of my murder what's up
I don't know
somebody's gonna make an actual like
escape room puzzle box out of that
hahaha
get it
[Music]
wow what a Time Saver
she's like a former lover of Miles she
aware of the murderer Among Us
everyone is sus
IE what y'all trying to do for me here
we're worried about you buddy you
haven't left the bath for a week oh
that's hyperbole
someone here for you
the Box
[Music]
dude
nice
this has a bit of a swashbuckling Vibe
all right Peter Steven Sondheim too
crazy little celebrity
quadriforce there takes place
specifically in 2020 but feels like out
of an earlier era than even Knives Out
was and it's got like a more
stylized kind of overall package
disruptor others have assembled
absolutely
ladies and gentlemen whoa welcome to
Greece what my man I did not realize
what the cast was I know but first i'm
gonna need you to remove your mask and
extend your tongue this will only be
momentarily uncovered wow
I wonder if he's got glass in those
loafers
that's some kind of disinfectant you're
good have a great trip everyone that's
the last we see of Ethan Hawke you might
be right I feel like I could be
our Femme Fatale there's definitely like
a little bond in this you know I was
thinking that too yeah it's like bond in
Indiana Jones and Agatha Christie one
legal move cut her out completely
booted her without a dime social network
oh Eddie norden's miles whiskey
wow I just I love that necklace
great
how are you doing
uh what
good friends Andy
and you're here
I am
all right
we got a great weekend just our gang
just us hey
hey bro not here oh is that uh Noah
seagan
a proper tour
of the Glass Onion oh yes here we go
like their bar yeah
it's like an actual huge Glass Onion
it's what came before where I am now
what I'll leave to the world ignore me
laughs
I just want to have a normal weekend
with my old friends like the old days
right I mean
[Laughter]
I'm sorry but that is just crazy I know
hey Mr Blanc we have a quick word so I'm
gonna die
what's the most impossible scenario to
do with it
is that a motor car
oh yeah that's my baby blue it's one of
a kind goes anywhere I go why is it on
the roof
I mean you received a box yes the wooden
box was delivered to my home with some
it's part of the game yeah is there any
way to close them again to to reset them
someone reset the Box
someone reset the Box they sent it to
you who reset the box
look at this pool I think I'll go for a
swim
that's their competition oh no maybe
only out for a bit
hey I want to look that good in anything
believe in yourself do you remember the
night you almost pancake me was it on
the road outside Anderson Cooper's
birthday
coops parties are memorable maybe this
isn't the MCU
H really Duke
you never know when shit's gonna go down
fought each other inspector
I preferred that
say I blame you oh whoa good reveal
disruptive what does that mean well some
people think Birdie's disruptive every
time she opens her mouth
sure
she was a fashion icon and then the
youngest editor ever of shishi magazine
then there was the whole thing with the
Halloween costume it was a tribute to
Beyonce but people did not take it that
way oh God
she blackface it probably I'm gonna yeah
if you want to shake things up you break
a norm or an idea or a convention some
little business model but that's the
place where you have to look within
yourself are you willing to break the
thing that nobody wants you to break yes
sign me up
we all got to that line
and crossed it
that's right Papa Elon
knows who Lionel works for that's no
secret and we know who bankrolled
Claire's campaign
nobody would touch birdie with a 10-foot
pole because she went on Oprah and
compared herself to Harriet Tubman oh my
God yeah
when Duke got banned from twitch for
Hawking Rhino horn boner pills to
teenage boys with zero rhinos
YouTube and use their media Empire to
promote the Stream
that is the common thread here
every single one of you is holding on
for dear life to Miles bronze golden
titties
for myself
well if miles is a system he must be
broken oh some people can't handle it
it's a dangerous thing the mistakes
speaking without thought for speaking
the truth oh great luck great luck
[Laughter]
I'm gonna post that to my status
if you make her go through with it her
name is destroyed
I'm sorry
uh
it is her only way out
clearly have the means that's a great
frame
less
find find the batteries take them out
[Music]
I mean you must have seen this coming
how
so many great lineup shots
oh my God it's so nice to hear this song
in a movie
I love this song What
is
Jeremy renders small batch hot sauce I
let him invest he sends me like a
palette every year take a few bottles
why would you hang a framed print of the
Mona Lisa front and center it's like
having a che poster in your dorm
it's the Mona Lisa
you blame it on the Pando Blanc louvers
closed France needed money and so I
bought myself a little short-term loan
nice security because most of the cost
check this out
oh my God
oh my gosh it's so freaking sensitive a
phone digs it closes up it's ridiculous
but I needed to be able to lick her in
the eyes
so much glass
it really is something
it's classic terrible
I'm gonna unveil
future
use solid hydrogen fuel it's incredibly
powerful it's radically efficient and
it's derived from abundant seawater
call it clear with a k
clever with a K
cool Claire and I are not going to be
responsible for putting something out in
the world before it is tested and
they're surrounded by it
if anyone
can name the Killer
tell me how they achieved the murder and
most importantly
what was the motive
that person wins our game what are we
wearing what do you mean what do you
what do you want
[Laughter]
fine yeah no no the winner gets an iPad
no
have we started already is it well the
murder hasn't happened oh but
who planted a Remote device on a
crossbow in Revenge for you stealing her
signature Ren diamond
oh
God that is a vintage Jayhawk brand
crossbow
Jayhawk buddy Jay Micah he's doing it
he's doing it whoa what became known as
the ren diamond and then that's a family
heirloom I believe to be clear I mean I
didn't know what a blood diamond was
what
would you kindly open it for us woof
wow oh my God you're ruining the party
give the man an iPad you have two iPads
it's a perfect contrast first movie I
just felt like the most satisfied
here's the iPad
I ruined your game on purpose you've
taken seven people each of whom has a
real life reason to wish you harm and
place the idea of your murder in their
heads
it's like putting a loaded gun on the
table and turning off the lights it's
protecting you man sketched out the
original idea for Alpha on cocktail
napkin and I showed it to Andy one night
at the Glass Onion
how's our local bar God damn I missed
that bar
well build a new one you could build a
hundred of them so someone else has to
die Maybe
yeah miserable in Paradise we've all
earned this yes you have
[Laughter]
[Music]
fine you got yours yours no he
from me
Claire's trying to
find us for sorry
we feel bad for you
I'm tired of pretending like you're the
thing you're the loser there
that's the truth
that's cruel
what is about to go down
feel the tension they're all about to
die there it is there's my guy what's
going on you look like you got good news
I was wondering why my goose are blowing
up reviews on my channel are off the
charts you got to see this
did he record
it's fire
D it sure does I was like this
you buy those views you're staying yes
you're staying okay love you this feels
more like into the invitation than
anything else oh good good call yeah
birdie that's amazing just just watch
this dress watch spin that dress again
everybody miles says look at me
freaking Mona Lisa what is about to go
down
on your feet genius I want to see your
Duke
oh no no not him
not my dude
[Music]
oh why him
who gave him that drink they were
pre-prepared you're not saying it was
done with intention are you well we
don't know
my guess is something was put in his
drink
yeah guys obviously
what if this was the elaborate plan the
whole time from Eddie Norden when we
will convene here
and walk together to the dock I'll stay
up all night but the body make sure it's
not tampered with it anyway I reckon
it's meant for me
was meant for him yeah oh
he picked up mine
foreign
I'll pay you one billion dollars to tell
me which one of them tried to kill me
do it make that make the bag
this phone look
oh the gun my murder game we were gonna
be having drinks and I thought it'd be
fun to say something dramatic just at 10
o'clock and then we're gonna have 20
minutes where help me
what happens at 10 o'clock
what this beer God oh not today
this can't be any it's just too off it'd
be too obvious but what if that's a
subversion of expectations and I plunk
did it
listen did you take Duke's gun I'm gonna
take Duke's gun and why are the lights
dude what
it's a great Motif with the lighthouse
oh cool that's this Ethan Hawke I don't
know Kate Hudson we only need one last
piece of information but only you can do
it
maybe miles
is doing it and is trying to kill them
all
[Music]
no this is like a tragedy she can't be
dead only one person can tell us who
killed Cassandra brand
10 years ago
you crap is this Benoit blocks residency
[Music]
is someone here for you
with a box
foreign
[Laughter]
oh interesting my name is Helen brand
two days ago I received a call my twin
sister committed
huh
fascinating my sister was Cassandra
brand and I'm just thinking about what
was taken from my sister and I'm getting
angrier and angrier and then I just hear
her knock at the door and it's some
carrier with this thing from Miles Braun
shot
sent this at 4 pm the day she was
murdered four days ago I finally found
it it's right here
and I'm going to use it to burn his
whole empire no you know where to find
me hey
that which can be destroyed by the truth
I searched every inch of every room in
her house and guess what wasn't
there the Red Envelope damn
it's like clue oh my God he's putting up
an act this whole time you come with me
to that Island
as your sister
Sandra brand is that why miles was so
surprised to see her oh maybe one of
those [ __ ] killed my
she's great yeah it's miles hey nice to
meet you bro hey first nobody liked him
he wants to create something that feels
lasting that feels this first Venture
was movie phoned for foot massages did
it work no
he got birdie a show for our designs it
did well got Lyle published Duke set up
at twitch Claire elected locally
back you know small stuff but it
happened building a cult the thing
happened
what is that you're working on
no Andy Andy come on this is it it's
just exactly like Steve Jobs
subtlety miles had the lawyers work the
contract so she was cut out the company
completely so she sued over there her
whole case was based on intellectual
ownership of the company's founding idea
her idea on the napkin
which she didn't keep oh God damn he had
an idea uh so he grabbed an apple and he
[ __ ] locked me in the eye Claire you
know it's a lie it's a lie
and do you recall Mr Cody oh you all
deserve to die right after the verdict
miles suddenly found them
handwriting and did all those interviews
about it bold face fabrication a damn
lie tomato tomato
true
no way oh is that what was in the
envelope it's the original
motive opportunity hey
this kind of looks like that yes I love
them together I know he's always got to
get paired up with a young scared but
strong woman
it's the major Trope of the knives out
Universe then we're all settling in
bro's gonna pull me aside to explain my
presence that is your chance to snoop
snoop
Snoop
nope this is brilliantly done yeah God
damn I'm loving this it's completely
recontextualized in the first hour
that's so smart I don't really like wow
what the hell re-watch this would be
yeah all the different Clues tells
I know I sold my soul for this you're
telling me that
it literally turned people's homes into
the hinden park
cool hidden homes there was a time you
know back when
moment
I thought you said you didn't drink
that's hard kombucha that's Jared Leto's
heart kombucha
you need to stop
because as it turns out nobody wants you
to break ah [ __ ] she was drunk can we
talk about the email you did even write
back
that's why I called
when we couldn't reach you
I went to your house
Lionel and I got there at the same time
oh my God they'll do it together
probably you were already there he
almost got in an accident on his
motorcycle he was driving so fast
okay okay
can you say all that one more time for
me please
okay but none of them fessed up to
haven't had a conversation yep
and they would have had to have snuck
something in her drink it's a great use
of the suspicions from earlier too
everyone's like she's not quite right
this case confounds me it just confounds
oh we don't have a motive for Duke or
birdie do either of you two want to do a
session or what oh my God it's live
Lionel Lionel faction hold on it doesn't
necessarily mean you know well right now
go to him we really need
to do this for me one last time okay
oh
he stuck her on him ew
oh ah no wonder it wasn't like yeah okay
oh is this twisted
[Music]
clever an email from the sweetypants
contractor two years ago
inviting to inform you that the proposed
Bangladesh factories notoriously one of
the world's biggest sweatshops please
advise
sounds perfect thanks oh oh you great
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
please tell me you did not
are where they
sweaters sweatpants
oh geez you said if I take full
responsibility for the sweatshops he'll
pay me the value of my shares 30 million
I have my secret no
whoever killed your sister took that
envelope to protect miles they wouldn't
just destroy it that would want him to
see what they'd done for him they
brought it here they'll have to hide it
in their room with dinner tonight smart
yeah we have to find that envelope
you're the loser that's the truth
there it is there it is
[Music]
woof
[Music]
hey
Daryl damn it
[Music]
okay oh no oh no
it has broken
ah
oh no oh no no no no he didn't deserve
this
he deserved what he
would and you are better off with
that
[Music]
what the [ __ ] oh damn don't kill me oh
my God I'm not trying to kill you you
crazy [ __ ] please
God who's the killer this is really hard
yeah it's in the glass you know if I can
distract everyone and you can get up
there and find it no but that doesn't
tell us who gave it to him we only need
one last piece of information but only
you can do it
[Music]
even though you can see it coming okay
but still
[Music]
what
play dead
protected you from Beyond the Grave uh
that's why I said leave her body
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I was nice what right at the center
so it was just miles I guess
what it teased my brain through this
entire case
in abbreviate
yeah I thought that earlier
fully abbreviate this moment
it's wonderful is a disaster his grasp
of disruption theory is remedial of best
[Laughter]
nobody tried to kill you your vain
glorious buffoon Duke took my glass
that's what you told us he did
he did what did we all actually see wow
look at that dress bin Bertie that's
amazing just just
you hand it too nice
when Duke got to Andy's house early on
his motorcycle
[Music]
was almost struck by him damn you
remember that night you almost pancake
me with it on the road outside of
Anderson Cooper's birthday
[Music]
focus on the envelope
foreign
threat until it was too late
but he didn't know Andy was dead no no
he didn't know that until this evening
when he got a Google alert on his phone
which is which is Fallen strangely
silent
which he showed to you
right out in the open Duke showed him
the changes things right
sure does maybe we can talk Alpha news
bet your ass come here
what are the ingredients you all Cuban
Breeze
a vodka Amaretto oh God
is he allergic to almonds
[Music]
no pineapple now right oh pineapple yeah
he just put pineapple juice in his
whisket
it's so dumb
it's a clue you have a loaded gun
conveniently Within Reach
it's like putting a loaded gun on the
table and turning off the light
uh
door one murder with any
bullet idea from me
Jesus so it was ever fired it and then
you be capable of making the shot he's
got a good aim at least how could you
ever prove that that's the original she
might have copied mine
the bar closed nine years ago and hers
has one thing to choose
ah yeah I just noticed that too yeah
okay but second
[Music]
oh oh
you [ __ ] well did you see just proof
this smoking napkin Blanc did anybody
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
everybody seems to have very foggy
recollection of what they actually saw
and there's nothing but
totally circumspective evidence so if
your sister was a complicated woman but
she meant the world to me
raise your hand and say
and say I saw him that night at Andy's
house y'all suck on his Tate
golden teat I have to answer to the
police the courts the system there's
nothing I can do oh that's heartbreaking
except maybe
offer you some courage
and a reminder of why your sister walked
away in the first place
is there something I'm missing
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
Chuck she's good when she drinks chug
[Music]
wreck the Mona Lisa
[Music]
wanted them a nugget of fear hell yeah
hell yeah
foreign
yes
turn the room
okay
[Music]
this must have been a fun day on set
I think that belonged to Liberace okay
are we done
go for Mona what what is it what do you
want
ah
we're not
oh God whoa
so play is gonna explode
it all down
walk away with a reminder of why my
sister walked away in the first place
oh
[Music]
reduce it to Ash
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
less Garden
disruption
[Music]
those cars wrecked the whole empire
come on
yep yep
[Music]
that's awesome
beautiful
no
like
[Laughter]
oh yep
what you've done watch that expression
oh
God it's all Core built off of that
oh your feel of the future just
barbecued the world's most famous
painting you dumbass and now you'll be
mentioned in the same sentence forever
yeah exactly and you did get your wish
or be remembered
[Music]
we know what happened
I saw the napkin he burned
I clearly saw him grab Duke's gun
I saw him driving away from Andy's house
the night she was killed
you ready to go home
yeah
and the next movie he'll be paired up
with an Asian girl that's right
[Music]
well done dope
all right
he ruined the first Knives Out ah they
woke it
that was great yeah that was a lot of
fun it was solid
that Ryan Johnson just loves those
subversions
smart because it seems so obvious that
it would be
ever Norton yeah
but I was like I actually did the thing
that I said look it's too obvious so you
can't suspect him yeah I notice him but
the movie threw me for a loop when
because it did seem like someone was
targeting him yeah did a good job at
that
oh because I didn't I didn't really
suspect anyone
else other than like
so I was like okay if it might be Andy
but then uh
when she was dead it was like I don't
really suspect anyone else yeah
it's like none of them
have enough reason to kill her yeah
but then I don't know they kept throwing
you for a loop it's like the first
prediction that's kind of the first
movie kind of does that yeah her sevens
were like might be Chris Evans and then
it steers you off that road yeah totally
and then you're like oh no it is yeah
yeah yeah yeah the misdirect but no you
should stick with your gut instead all
along yeah anyhow I mean you're you're
designed to sit there and go like okay
well maybe there's some kind of hidden
detail that we don't know yet about all
these different characters but
all right we'll shitty chatter
put on my neck scarf doesn't match this
outfit but I brought it for just this
occasion perfect Benoit Blanc scarf
perfect yeah well well well well
um I liked it quite a bit I liked it a
lot I enjoyed it a lot
um
that was fun it's a fun game to play
along with absolutely yeah and uh I
really
did you it's coming off of knives out
you know like I'm not here to do a
comparison thing but coming off of
knives out after having that fresh in
your mind because I saw it that one time
in the theaters which I thought was a
magical like I thought the first if
there's one like off the cuff
uh comparison I'd make it because like
structurally they're very different
obviously and I actually love that
because you don't need to watch the
first one yeah at all yeah like you
really don't need to watch the first one
whatsoever to to like to appreciate this
film or understand it or follow it or
even like it you know
um so I do think that it makes for a
great complimentary piece because of the
fact of how different it is I think you
might appreciate aspects of it more if
you watch the first one but I love that
you don't need to watch it whatsoever uh
there's a there's like a rare kind of
sequel to make yeah absolutely I mean
coming off of Knives Out fresh in your
mind what'd you think fresh in my mind I
thought this was yeah a terrific way of
building on that and looking back at the
original movie like it's still held up
for my viewing experience there are a
couple times where I feel like it maybe
thinks it's a little bit more Grand than
it actually is but I think here they
managed to kind of take that Grandeur
and Infuse it even even more like the
first movie is is great because of its
restraint and because of how it's
playing on a more austere version of the
genre and this version is is like we
were saying you know is going into a
more broad more swashbuckling more sort
of you know James Bond scope and I
appreciated that and I appreciated how
this played off of like in the first
movie Benoit Blanc is like he has such a
Mystique and he's so cool uh for so much
of it and you know even the way they
introduce him he's like always in the
background just observing and then he
slowly implements himself into the plot
and here I thought they played off of
that really well and just in these few
moments since the movie The more I've
thought about it just the more it feels
like
it took the ball from the first movie
and the way it wanted to subvert those
expectations and I feel like there's
something about the first movie where I
can imagine certain people being like
wait wait wait the subversion ah you
know like is it truly fully satisfying I
think here uh he managed to layer
multiples on top of that have multiple
kind of games going at once and so yeah
I thought it was a fantastic way to
build on it to take the personality of
the first movie but also do its very own
thing this time and yeah having that one
connective tissue of Ben Wa Blanc and
giving him just enough like extra
character here to flesh him out as a
continuing character if you do want to
pay attention to it establish is gay
he's gay he's gay I mean they brought up
donut holes that's true the first one
was a clear metaphor and the donut hole
in the donut and the donut little donut
yeah which was the first indication so
it shouldn't come as too big of a
surprise no
um but I mean that wasn't just his
Butler I I did I yeah I thought this was
fine I think the you know the first
movie left me with a feeling of of a lot
of awe and I was like I was in love with
that one and I thought it was really
intense too sure and so this this leaves
you with a different feeling and I and I
feel like the the first obvious feeling
I had with this one is oh this would
make for one hell of a re-watch sure yes
which I didn't quite get I imagine
Knives Out is a great re-watch I haven't
done it but but because of the way this
movie is structured where it does set it
up of okay they're doing like a a
different they're doing a sequel they're
doing a part two where instead of you
know Benoit Blanc being a uh super
badass who's who's uh brought onto this
case and everything and it has this
mystery surrounding him he's you know
kind of in the slumps here the pandemic
and the mentality is really affecting
him and he feels like a stranger caught
off guard and uh he looks like the odd
man out out of this group of everyone
who really knows him he he seems like
the least knowledgeable one fish out of
water it will be the quality here you
know and I and then to find out that oh
he's not yeah he's been very much in
control this whole time that's what I
mean by the flip Roo like I thought it
was really cool how they really at the
middle of this movie they literally go
over the first hour yeah and you see it
from the perspectives of Helen and Bena
Blanc
um Benoit Blanc from his uh actual real
involvement I thought was really that
was cleverly done yeah and it made me go
I want to re-watch this just because of
that because like the last movie
has an immediate kickoff death point
right and and then games afoot we're
here you're like okay
something's happen something's going to
happen yeah yeah something hasn't
happened what is the game exactly and
because of the fact that you know it's
got to be a big murder mystery due to
they're setting up that stage for it
obviously with the with the game and uh
but also being the fact that it is a
part two you know like there's something
coming so you have that built-in faith
that something's about to happen but
you're waiting a while you're in like 45
minutes before something for that real
plot actually takes off and kicks into
high gear you know and uh and you're
spending time with all these characters
and learning A Whole New World and and
the the world that they're setting in is
very like what I call like social media
topical yeah totally everything every
character represents a faction of the
now part of the yeah faction of the the
current conversation especially from the
pandemic yeah and on like it doesn't go
fully you know into it's political
commentary oh [ __ ] it's like a thousand
persons cultural commentary at least
yeah yeah yeah no a thousand percent
um you even have the Edward Norton
character as a as a play on the
billionaires who don't really know
anything but they know how to take
advantage and use people and take all
the credit yeah you know and I mean to
see Edward Norton like I appreciate that
he is so down for roles like that
because it is a very unflattering
character that he plays very well yeah a
good sleazeball yeah uh I I enjoyed I
enjoyed that uh quality quite a bit and
the kit the characters are I think every
actor here is really solid I think
everyone's great
um yeah I mean totally I do love the
flipper that they do boy the
um Blanc in this movie because you you
don't even see that reveal really coming
yeah but there are those hints of it
especially with the fact that he doesn't
seem suspect at all about like if you
look at the first half of this movie he
doesn't seem suspect that much suspect
about Andy yeah even when she's gone
missing and and Bautista's dead I mean
he just goes up to her and talks to her
yeah you know okay interesting choice
yeah oh no this makes makes a lot of
sense I mean similar to how anode armis
was the scene stealer of that film uh
it's like Janelle Monae in this movie is
is that Replay that supplement yeah
which is very it's very I think that's
the most like obvious comparison too is
like you should pair them off and then
you have Janelle Monae who's kind of
like the odd one out yeah totally you
have these and people who have been
wronged by the circumstances and the
systems put in place by the very
environment that they're in who he's
eventually going to basically Empower to
take back you know what uh has been
slighted them by all these messed up
circumstances I do remember the first
movie coming out around Thanksgiving
which felt appropriate because it was a
play on dysfunctional family yeah and
the big family gathering where this is
like Caribbean Vibes yeah yeah coming
out of Christmas
beautiful sandy beaches and whatnot yeah
I mean it is an interesting contrast and
hey I mean maybe it'll be a nice break
from the cold for people yeah but I do
think some of the I do think some of the
sometimes comment certain kinds of
commentary can feel extremely on the
nose in this movie and then some of the
more like celebrity call out names and
stuff like that yeah I mean if it's the
environment in the world but it brings
it kind I want to say it pulls me out
however it does make me aware even more
so of the screenplay sure the screenplay
is a character yeah when you do [ __ ]
like that yeah because this movie is
like filled with it you know it is yeah
in the first movie is much more
insulated to its own universe and I'm
I'm still kind of chewing on how I feel
about that because I think there's
certain aspects of this one that
coalesce a little bit better even for me
because like the cast in the first movie
is great
um and there are times where I feel like
they just kind of Revel in that a bit
where at in certain moments it would
take me out of the overall of the
situation go oh man whoever I'm looking
at right now is having a lot of fun or
something like that whereas here I
thought like they really coalesced all
together and it wasn't just this amazing
cast of people but I really believed the
kind of whole unit of their different
friendships and their overlapping
motivations and whatnot in a way that
felt a bit more Earnest in a sense and a
bit more a bit less self-aware at least
from how it was all played out through
the acting I think it's clever of how he
met with a complimentary piece again now
the first movie's uh oh it's a family
but they're not a real loving family and
this is a friend group and they've been
best friends forever but they're not a
real friend group yeah yeah yeah it's
all conniving underneath yeah and
everyone had a great personality and I
think the way they they when especially
when you flip the movie halfway through
when it is okay not who would kill miles
but who would kill Andy when you get to
the both
but especially with Andy not I like I
think with Miles and you're like okay
maybe this person maybe this room when
it came to the time with Andy you're
like well any one of them could have
done it yeah any one of them has a
motive now yeah to to kill them yeah
let's kill Andy and I love that too
though like the way I feel like part of
the knives out franchise you know
formula now has to be that the central
murder or whatever is a subversion of
some kind and I thought here they did a
really satisfying job of that because
it's like he says yeah you brought
everybody here you planted the idea of
your own murder in everyone's head
with the audience as well and then yeah
you have this uh prior murder that is
much like I think the more I've thought
about it because there is a certain
element of like oh it's just it's just
him he's the most likely per it would
have to be him in a way uh but at the
same time I thought that fit the theme
really well and everybody is a layer on
the Glass Onion but he is the center of
it you know he is you know the core that
they're all trying to cling to for fear
of being peeled away well what I would
say about even even though you know it
was like he would be the obvious suspect
because the movie tries throwing you off
of that scent and I bought into the
scent I took the bait yeah basically is
what I did yeah especially with you know
there's even a line at one point where
uh Helen does say something about what
about miles and he says hi it would be
that dumb or yeah yeah and then coming
down to how dumb he actually is using
that need that sort of uh uh you know
like chronic need to yes take ideas and
reappropriate them and then claim them
as your own like it's it's it's woven
again like in the moment you could be
like oh really it's just him but then
the amount of detail it laces in to
support that and I love that little
thing about all the misnomer words that
he's throwing out because it's one of
those details that in the moment you
catch but then you don't have enough
time you know to kind of be like wait a
minute is that a real word though it's
like kind of go off on that tangent and
yeah like I thought it was really
tightly wound on those details and the
amount of those details that were given
to every character or even a character
like whiskey there was way more to than
and you would expect whereas like and
again let's just keep on comparing but
you have like certain Side characters in
the first film that are just kind of
there and don't get much flesh whereas
here keeping it a little more contained
to a smaller slightly smaller group I
think enabled them to really Heap the
richness onto most everybody say for
maybe Jessica henwick but you know even
her presence I still appreciate it
overall well what was cool about this it
wasn't until
um
when when uh Blanc dismantles the whole
murder mystery game that Edward Norton
has set forth yeah because it is just
like such an ensemble movie where it
doesn't even feel like a Knives Out
sequel yeah and it doesn't even feel
like blonk's movie or Adventure yeah
he's on because you're just waiting for
the the thing to kick off and then when
the glasses pull I mean the curtains
pulled back then you find out oh you've
been watching kind of blanc's game this
whole time yeah and I think that's
really clever too like no this is still
his movie yeah he's not only is the
killer steps ahead but so is he already
before we're even aware but even with
the Edward Norton ultimate reveal what I
what I didn't catch was the even though
he was a prime suspect number one and
would be the most likely one and was the
most obvious pick it the when they did
do the cutaways to show like this was
shown to you in the movie already that
he what that he is the one who did it
yeah when they're doing those cutaways
that Ryan Johnson puts in the edit I
didn't catch that just based purely off
of motive and stuff was the one but all
those things like with the thing with
the glass switching and uh taking the
gun yeah all those things are like okay
yeah yeah that that is clever it is it's
it is a it's still a very like clever
film and I I really I didn't I didn't
like it a lot I wouldn't say I loved it
though there was something about that
that's been the only thing I've been
trying to sort of figure out of what
what is the thing that's kind of holding
me back from saying I I love this film
because I would actually agree with you
when it comes to that about the
characters but I think I still actually
enjoyed the Ensemble more and it's not
even just off comparison like I said
it's been a few years since I've seen
knives out and I saw it one time so it's
not like I have this High reverence
before Knives Out to the point where I'm
like I'm just gonna be watching this
comparing it it's more remembering the
feeling that the last one left me with
and that one I I think uh something
maybe it might have just been because it
was family Dynamic that I'm just more
drawn to naturally of a dysfunctional
family that I I think is a easier
emotional click to it uh but the
characters here while I enjoyed everyone
I I didn't I wouldn't say I I loved
watching most of them like no one was
really quite uh Edward Norman kind of
comes like kind of known was really
quite a Chris Evans to me to get
deliciously despicable or something like
that and I feel and it's interesting
because there are things about that in
the first movie that maybe take me out
of the coalescence of things but it's
not there's no denying yeah that he is
Chris Evans for example in that movie
among many other characters is
delightful to watch and especially to
watch him have so much fun being such a
dastardly character even though uh yeah
like you know the ultimate core of where
that's going and here I feel like this
movie has a much more like the first
movie is a more classic sensibility is a
bit more analog sensibility and so
you're kind of again contained within
its world and it's while there are
certain nods to you know just current
life there's not a lot of that whereas
here this is very very of the now and
the characters are despicable in a more
modern kind of way in that a lot of them
are very vapid and spineless and and
yeah even though they're all kind of
interesting in their own way because of
what the actors bring to them
um I don't know yeah there's there's
maybe something a little less colorful
or or truly unique about them like they
all feel like they kind of came from the
same set whereas it Knives Out the first
one you have
kind of do you have different
Generations you have different you know
modes of this wealth Empire you know
different uh leverages in that sense
whereas everybody here is kind of under
the same circumstance well it felt like
a a Hollywood movie pair up of
archetypes yeah in this friend group you
know sure yeah because the friend like
okay this person's running for Senate
that's the governor character yeah this
person's the chemist yeah this person is
the influencer you know and uh there so
there was it was that thing where there
I was very I guess this time around this
movie just made me so much more aware
that I was more impressed structurally
with the film like I was never quite I
didn't find it suspenseful
I didn't find it like intense it was
always fun and and it is cathartic yeah
and it was fun to play with it was fun
to play along with the movie you know to
to me to sort of try to figure it out
and and see what the ultimate reveal is
and I think Janelle Monae is phenomenal
oh yeah so I think she's phenomenal in
this like her and Daniel Craig are
awesome in here yeah
um but yeah this this was more uh of a
more structurally impressive experience
to me than anything else yeah I feel
like the writing and directing are like
the main star and then everybody else is
a supporting character of The Ensemble
yeah yeah they're filming that all in
yeah and so and and I appreciate that in
the sense that you can take these as to
very unique experiences unto themselves
and I can imagine various people having
wildly different opinions about which
one they like more but I do appreciate
that the core of both movies is Blanc
and whoever is the sort of good-hearted
person in the middle of all these
despicable other characters trying to
you know gain some kind of reclamation
or do the right thing and I think that
this nails that certainly and yeah it's
I'm interested to see how the following
day is kind of ensue it when where this
movie settles for me because on the
surface the first movie has slightly
more things that just for me personally
as a viewer maybe take me out or maybe
feel like okay you're not quite quite as
like god tier right now as you as you
seem to kind of be playing it as you are
but at the same time looking at this
that like they were on the surface so
many things that felt kind of so tight
and that at least in an experiential way
smoothed out those gripes I would have
had and yet yeah I still kind of wonder
if the first one would still be my
favorite just because of the things that
so much of it does coalesce in a way
that truly does feel distinct and all
the characters do feel
kind of completely of their own thing
rather than cut of a similar cloth and
kind of riffing variations on the same
sort of set of people
um I don't know either way like they're
both really satisfying and I appreciate
the way that Ryan Johnson is able to pay
tribute to a classic genre and also
bring a lot of new and interesting
sensibility to it and the first one
gives you that package of like an Agatha
Christie type of movie and this one
gives you a package of something much
more modern but I I still think that
they managed to kind of Eek A Classic
quality out of it sure yeah I haven't
seen death on a knob but this feels like
we're death on a Nile might be and I've
heard that too it's like never death on
the Niles like it's been more fun it's
about where wild the mystery isn't quite
as hard to crack but still like there's
a lot of great work
you know yeah there's some good there's
some good unveils all around and I think
for um I think for Janelle Monae I think
that was a just she had to play both
characters and I thought she did an
Exquisite job on both yeah and it's a it
is a again it's like a it would I never
doubt it this is the first thing I never
doubt it's another really well shot film
and Incredibly incredibly edited oh yeah
on top of all that it's like clockwork
this yeah yeah no no it is like a it's
like watching a surgeon go to work yeah
yeah and it's got enough sort of Quirk
and esoterica that it's just like kind
of engrossing on its own for how
outlandish it is and it doesn't feel too
outlandish for how colorful a lot of the
things are I don't understand Ethan
Hawke being here I like I think the Hue
Grant Cameo is way more of a of a well
utilized celebrity Cameo sure even
though it's less of a screen time
um the fact that he is like a character
who plays a an emotional purposeful part
to uh Blanc works and to get was he
doing a Southern accent or is he just
British I couldn't tell what I was like
am I not hearing who Grant's voice
properly it's been a while yeah yeah I
thought I I thought he was just Hugh
Grant but I would have to go back and
look at it it's still fun to have him
there I think Ethan Hawke was like I'm
so aware I'm watching Ethan Hawk that
felt like is just here to be Ethan
Hawke's doing what Ethan Hawk would do
with this for a couple minutes that very
much felt like one of those things where
it's like oh I would love to be in oh
yeah I just come down for a day you know
I've got a part for you sure like jump
in yeah and like it's fun but yeah it
doesn't it doesn't feel as clever as
something like Hugh Grant because Hugh
Grant you hear his voice and you get
that satisfaction being like Oh that's
who that was it's like he was here the
whole time
but did the pandemic I I thought it was
interesting they set this during the
pandemic did it is there something I'm
missing did it quite I thought it would
have more of a factor
I guess yeah like they're they're it's
brought up tangentially but it just
seemed like kind of an interesting
opportunity I guess to to
use the here and now as an excuse to get
them in an isolated location like it
doesn't seem incredibly purposeful
because you know it's like the thing
he's working on is off that way yeah
yeah I mean it feels like yeah it's a
very distinct part of the movie and I
and I like that you have that at least
affecting Blanc in a way where he's like
it seems like he's cooped up and partly
is just there's not a case right now but
it seems like I don't know maybe there's
no murder happening yeah
there's less big old murder cases
happening around him or whatever
um but yeah it's not like Edward
Norton's working on some kind of
biopharmaceutical thing you know he like
that could have factored in it could
have been a 2022 movie it could be a 20.
it could be any time yeah yeah yeah yeah
so I feel like that was just them kind
of using their surroundings or or
something well it wasn't even really
just the pandemic it was really they
utilized like 20 20. yeah you know yeah
I mean because yeah like they are that's
what every one of these people is kind
of a commentary on yeah it's a very
2020s kind of situation that's the core
of all this we are at the time of
disruptors and all these people who are
like pseudo influencer business slash
political figures well it doesn't go
sci-fi but there are there are some
semis if I quite like the whole thing
with the hydrogen explosion thingy of uh
clear yeah
um like that's a an invention that's a
Bond movie yeah it's a Bond movie that's
all the setting it's kind of a bond yeah
this takes place at like the evil
masterminds headquarters except he's
really dumb and bond doesn't need
gadgets he just needs his intellect yeah
like in some ways this does feel like
the audition tape for Ryan Johnson's uh
James Bond movie or something like that
because that's like even though there
are again like we said more classic kind
of romanticized swashbuckling Vibes and
there's certainly the requisite Agatha
Christie sort of murder mystery Vibes
the most I got the most overt tone I got
was like a James Bond thing like this
all felt very James Bondi just with a
different Dynamic of how to solve the
case you know yeah and what that means
it's it's a it feels a little more
light-hearted to me a little quirkier
and yeah
somehow felt smaller somehow felt more
contained yeah even though you're on
this luxurious billionaire Island
and and the cast is bigger I think being
able to leave the house in the first
movie helped because you're like the car
chase yeah yeah because you get at least
a couple moments to remember there are
other people just out in the world you
know you're not just yeah it's not like
it almost feels like in a way using the
pandemic
Clues you into the fact that yeah they
probably had to keep this as spare as
possible so how do we know that's true
how do we shoot without extras and
needing to have crowds of any kind the
pandemic Vibe kind of looms throughout
sure so I think I think the backdrop of
the pandemic helps if anything it serves
more of a backdrop than it does as a
actual character in the film yeah it
doesn't seem like a real point of
emphasis for any particular subtext or
any sort of aspect or facet of the
mystery at large they gotta ring among
us into it yeah there you go well there
you go here it is it's the panda yeah
it's the pandemic of uh of of you know
of spinelessness and uh deceit you know
it's like all of them are infected by
the need to protect this guy and then
they are cured with the vaccine of Truth
and then eventually they fight back
I wanted them [ __ ] I wanted them all
to get their comeuppance though
because they're all horrible I don't
like any of these people like I don't
like any of them they're all horrible
people
yeah and there's something because it's
like it's weird because the first movie
they're mostly all horrible people too
but there are but they don't want what
do they want I want the will or some
[ __ ] is that yeah they're all they're
all back biting and then fighting on the
will but they still leave you it's like
even though Jamie Lee Curtis for example
is a hard ass there's still something
Charming about her at the end or the
daughter in that movie I think her name
is Meg uh she's like she is a pretty
sympathetic character in general or you
have the grandma who would again is a
total character doesn't speak really but
is somewhat sympathetic whereas here
yeah like
I don't know Leslie Odom Jr seems kind
of okay despite the fact that he too is
you know aboard this train and actively
putting people in danger so yeah it
seems like the only good people
really at all are Benoit and and Helen
and and yeah so that adds a certain I
guess maybe one I won't say one
dimensionality but it takes an element
of Dimension uh from most of like the
only other likable characters whiskey is
and I like that like I like that the
movie is is sort of uh
compassionate I guess I'll say enough to
be like here's a character who you know
these movies are designed for you to
make judgments and associations and you
know think of what you're presented with
and I liked here that they peeled back
those layers and made her an actual
character and and she's pretty likable
and you feel for the position she's in
from like the one brief scene you get of
her but yeah everybody else is pretty
much like oh you guys all made this bed
and you even though now you're kind of
coming around to the truth and coming
around to you know standing up to this
guy it literally took all this you know
and somebody else again doing all the
work for you well I didn't think too
that
they because I set up everyone's like
you know they all met with the Glass
Onion
um ages ago right at that bar
or they didn't meet there but that was
their thing and and then it's all these
years later and they're setting up their
backstories and the journeys they've
been on and and whatever
and I thought that I guess this was sort
of an expectation that I thought the
movie set up for me that all that would
have this like
Collision or I'll coalesce together in
some way but it sort of just seemed like
uh Dave Bautista's dead and who's trying
to kill Andy like he's kind of just
stopped in the in the middle of the
tracks and I like the direction it went
because what I what was cool
structurally about this film was it's
because it's setting all that up and
it's leading to the murder mystery game
and then I was like all right so what
they're doing is they're setting up
everyone's backstory so odds are what's
gonna happen is miles is probably going
to really die at this murder mystery and
who's the one who really killed him and
we've established everyone's backstory
so which so he's you think it's going to
go down that route right at least that's
what the movie's setting up to me yeah
is that it's going down that route of
miles is really gonna die at this thing
and then but Block's gonna have to do
his thing and investigate everyone's
backstory yeah some more and then try to
find out who's the one who really killed
miles
but then it doesn't do that yeah you
know that's the biggest subversion of
the expectation because you're like 45
minutes in uh Blanc just uproots the
whole thing you know blows the whole
game and it becomes a completely
different direction uh for the film
I still found myself craving because and
I think that's why I wanted like the
comeuppance or some [ __ ] you know it's
kind of just like it adds layers and it
makes makes the characters characters
more than just you know someone like
Kate Hudson could have just easily been
just that one note thing that she is you
know like you're just so dumb I don't
even I don't even know how you got this
far like this Miss films didn't have a
commentary of like rich people and
people in power are actual idiots and
that that's like a main takeaway for a
lot of these people they're all dumb you
know
um uh except for they didn't really do
that with Catherine Hahn
um no but they don't also really give
her no yeah
so I mean I thought that some of their
because they spent especially with
Edward given that great speech about
like everything they did that I thought
that would all somehow some of that
would come to the surface a little bit
more it could have been a way too packed
of a film if they did that yeah for sure
but there is a but the first one even
does have a bit of resolve for many of
the personal squabbles that were
happening outside of the main murder
mystery whereas this one there isn't
really much of that like you know you
don't you don't really know what awaits
any of them other than maybe they'll be
better people now this is miles is the
center of it but they're all they're all
they're terrible they were all terrible
yeah complicit in all this terrible
stuff the second they show the courtroom
scene with Andy I'm like oh you guys
suck I don't want any of you guys to
come out of this alive I hope you all
die yeah well and part of me it's weird
part of me thought they were going
yeah the sister was gonna make this
crazy sacrifice and I was like I don't
know exactly how I would feel about
Blanc for for you know
condoning that or pushing that but at
the same time it did feel like that
would be a very bold statement for the
movie to make it while I do like and
appreciate that the point is you know
it's not enough to have the evidence
because so much of the time in real life
crime and cases you have that problem of
there's just not enough evidence to
present even though we all know the
truth but yeah yeah so they've all got
to come around but but yeah that's more
of a function which is again a very like
20 20ish sure thing to oh yeah so that
became very topical yeah yeah and like I
like that as a theme I think it works
well for the the place and the setting
but it's a macro theme more than it is
like a personal character related theme
and this I don't think does quite as
much to have both whereas the previous
movie does a little bit more of that
it's like it's weird it's like the first
Knives Out in the immediate moment gave
me slightly more thing things to be like
a little not suspect of but I had like
slightly more little nitpicks and gripes
along the way but the longer term impact
I think is a bit greater whereas this
one like in the moment I was eating it
up and I and I would love to watch it
again like I I really liked it I think
the lasting impact will be a little bit
less yeah than the original movie but
yeah it's like it's still really tightly
wound and it's still really well
conceived for the most part I've thought
I might be and I could be wrong here
um because this movie did actually
really well in its limited release in
the theaters and it's got a great
response so far and I imagine almost any
movie is better in the theaters all
right regardless of course this movie is
is more than likely odds of it being
better in the theaters extremely high
you know uh and uh so I I understand
that sentiment but the movie did not
leave me with a feeling of I
I wish I had seen this in the theaters
or uh this would have been better like
even if I was at home alone with the
lights off I'm like yeah that's fine
watching this yeah Netflix yeah yeah I'm
not but I I wasn't thinking about it
even yeah yeah I mean I'd be happy to
see the theaters but it was yeah but I'm
not I'm not ditching or I'm Not Really
Gonna carve out time like that's the one
way to see it yeah yeah I don't I don't
have that urge it's like I saw
everything everywhere all at once I mean
Grant a very different kind of film and
it's very like cinematic visual feast
and all that
um but I like I reacted to that here and
then five days later I want to watch in
the theaters would be so because that
that leaves me with that feeling and and
knives out to me was such a Grand
Theater experience yeah yeah yeah and um
so again I don't know if I if I will
maybe maybe if I re-watch knives out at
home I'll be like oh you know maybe not
as strong as I thought it was because
it's hot at home
um but yeah this this this wasn't as to
me this this did kind of lack an
excitement factor I didn't find it quite
exciting I was always intrigued and I
was I was having fun but I wouldn't say
this was exciting I think that's a good
distinction to make is the difference
between yeah fun versus exciting and
like even though this has a more overtly
exciting package like yeah you you do
miss a certain amount of tension you're
always wondering you're always asking
you're always engrossed but it doesn't
necessarily feel like
anyone could die at any moment or
something like that or or you know that
like there's I don't know like if it
seems like it should feel more uh like
more intense because you have the
murderer lurking in your midst and at
one point you have that classic glove
shot and everything like that and it
yeah it doesn't it Quicken your heart
rate or make you go like oh man you know
is block gonna die you know what are
they gonna try and kill Blanc you know
yeah it's a bit more like okay but we
gotta keep going we gotta keep getting
these more details you know yeah well I
think it's really focused on doing its
mid point reveal yes yeah but but and
and to be fair I guess like even the
first movie had this effect on me
whereas like the the most engrossing and
the most sort of endearing thing is that
Central Duo of Blanc and whoever he's
helping right now and there were moments
where those pulled me in enough that I
forgot about like when I thought she was
just dead I like I completely forgot
about that because of how great
those scenes worked and I think that is
a true credit and that does add at least
some element of that tension but yeah
it's not as prevalent throughout and and
for as much as these bits and pieces are
overlapping they're much more
self-serving than they feel outwardly
threatening well I mean I I think the
only person you kind of care about is
block where you're only periodically
checking in with in the first half of
this movie and then and then the person
you become really emotionally
attuned to or or connected with as an
audience member would be uh the Helen
character right yeah because like at
least on my end I wasn't like we're
barely spending time with Andy and I'm
only hearing like
you know some information being dished
out yeah so I don't I'm not really
latched on to it in an emotional way
until you you get the reveal of Helen
and all that stuff which comes like
almost an hour into the film yeah
and like I said I'm only using knives
out as an example right now to say like
what what what worked for me there was
you do get really hooked into honor Day
armis on an emotional way yeah very
early on yes you do like it's it's one
of the she's like the main character of
that film and and they they set that up
yeah you're like oh halfway through
you're like oh cheese to me here yeah
yeah interesting cool subversion but
also we're yeah we're in and that's what
I meant by
um structurally it's it's a very a
really admire that's on a structural
experience like it's really unique in
that way but wasn't they didn't have
that main character where I was and I
think without having that main character
that limits me from feeling that
excitement or that or that intensity
yeah and then even with the whole thing
of because because even I was watching I
was like oh but she's gonna die oh she's
not dead okay cool they're kind of felt
like it wrapped up pretty fast yeah it's
like go up there we didn't think about
that like oh
oh that thing you've flat out said early
on to ignore yeah yeah yeah and and
there's also I feel like they almost
bridged the Gap with having Blanc be
such a fish out of water in the first
half because he does kind of take on
this
slight main character quality because
you do get a little bit of a personal
look into his life at least that he
doesn't know what to do he is and his
codery of very notable friends you know
uh trying to fill the hours between
cases and then having him come to this
party and be so kind of charmingly out
of place yeah I thought they were doing
the thing where oh it's blanc's gonna
have the ark yeah and it's like okay the
first movie he's such a figure he's such
a mystery and he makes you feel safe
because he's here and he's in control
and now oh it's the complete opposite
but then halfway through we go back to
oh no no he's in control and we're safe
yeah yeah and he is the Blanc I always
knew and expected he would be I just
know that at home he's a little more
disheveled because they they set you up
like oh belongs off his game yeah yeah
yeah he's only making this party worse
for himself
yeah and so it's like yeah again it's
like the structure I'm impressed but
then I'm also like okay but but now I'm
back to what I'm used to from the
character which is always great which is
always one of the best parts of both of
these movies is he is he is like the
casts of both of these are so great and
he is a perfect Center piece because he
is like kind of transcendent as this guy
like he just breathes this character and
so I'm not disappointed by that but I
feel like yeah if they had maintained
some of that fish out of waterness or at
least some element of that personal need
for the case throughout the movie that
could have maybe made it just yeah
emotionally attached or or you know kind
of complete that interesting thing they
bring up for the first half you know but
overall I still I still really liked it
a lot and it's hard to follow up a movie
like Knives Out yeah and I cannot wait
to see what the next one is yeah oh yeah
that's another thing I would blindly
chop at the bit and be excited for a
part three yeah because what I like I
like that this is like they've given in
the dissection of both these movies they
were just different things to appreciate
and different things where I'm like okay
this could have been a little bit more
whatever for me uh and so yeah it's it's
nice to have a situation where you know
eventually you'll have a preference one
over the other but to me they're sort of
neck and neck because they're both doing
something that is knives out but that
there is unique to each installment and
that kind of adds to that lovely you
know murder mystery novel quality where
yeah it's like you don't need to there
are certain like serial elements of
puero stories I think but I don't think
you necessarily have to read them all in
order or anything like that I think this
is shaping up to be nicely that way you
could peer in on any Blanc mystery and
pick your favorite because everyone's
gonna have a different favorite you know
well guys what did you think about Glass
Onion did you like it more than the
first did you like it just as much are
you kind of disappointed what's your
thoughts
subscribe leave a like last but not
least to send us for the patreon
Mikhail knew it for some reason I was
like yeah
because I imagine this you wind yourself
into a situation of grave proportions
and you need someone to crack the case
and come out who would make you feel the
most comfortable look at mikhail's
profile picture and tell me that if that
dude showed up in a snazzy suit with his
Spectacles on you wouldn't be like no I
gotta I gotta listen to this Swedish guy
he knows what he's doing and he can
crack Decay he's a sophisticated he's
seen every James Bond movie he's gonna
be ahead of the curve on all these
Mysteries and World rending plots and
whatnot and plus he's a good guy he's
been here forever you see Mikhail it's
like being greeted with a warm southern
accent except you know not that because
he's not from Louisiana and I feel like
you're you're a nice analogy for a movie
like this and I love you and I hope that
you continue to Grace our patreon page
for ages and Evers and I hope you're
having a good holiday season buddy I am
Merry Christmas and happy New Year buddy
[Music]